e
good morning everyone uh welcome to the
special committee on covid response
efficacy um I would like to ask uh
representative eel to leave us in the
uh just to remind everyone this
bipartisan committee is tasked with
investigating and evaluating the state's
response to the covid-19 pandemic the
committee will function as science-based
fact finding review specifically
acquiring comprehensive accurate data
and all related information pertaining
thereto areas of particular Focus will
include the administration of federal
guidance acceptance of federal funds and
implementation of emergency use
authorization vaccination efforts a
report will be issued outlining the
committee's findings and the impact on
New Hampshire uh today's meeting is to
discuss a draft report and uh go over
that so that a final report can be
submitted
um
[Music]
so representative where I know you've
made uh some changes already to the
draft report that we've received you
have suggested changes uh if you would
like to uh go over those and if anybody
else has anything uh they would like to
free yes
oh um
yes yes
um you go over
as I I think we should go over each
section individually and then suggest
changes so that everyone has a a chance
to discuss what they feel needs to be
changed or uh if there's any opposing
opinions or things that needed to be
added Etc so um
me representative evil I think it would
be helpful for um representative beler
just as a starting point to kind of
outline his thought process anything he
might want to say uh about the drafting
of this sure just to sort of introduce
it yeah and I and I think this should be
a pretty informal hearing so that we can
just have like a a a conversation
email thank you Madame chair and uh
thank you for um asking me to uh to
introduce the draft report
um this was a significant process to get
this uh draft completed um relying on a
combination of input from the committee
um trying to break it out into different
sections that would make sense um in
order to be reasonably comprehensive
while not unnecessarily repetitive um
spend a lot of time balancing ideas uh
for specific
language uh so we have uh the the
breakdown is three major sections with
each section containing um multiple
subsections the first section uh being
the introduction section the
acknowledgements which is basically just
a a broad overview outline and
sentiments around what we um have seen
and the way that we have undertaken this
evaluation noting for you know such
things that we're not undertaking this
with an eye toward um being unreasonable
we want to understand what happened as
it happened what was known at the time
not just utilizing hindsight which
should be 2020 um but giving people the
benefit of the fact that there was a lot
of Doubt uncertainty and fear involved
in this whole process um outlining our
mission uh a summary of findings which
really is just a brief breakdown of the
findings
um as far as our mission statement goes
relating to efficacy what efficacy means
what the goals were um a brief note on
the executive after Action Report which
um notes that the after Action Report
has certain utility in certain areas
especially things like some
Communications and inter-government
functions um but it's also not exactly
scientifically oriented so it does have
limited utility in certain other
areas um major section two policy areas
goes through subsections of uh setting
goals talks about how goals were set um
what was testified to the committee as
far as what the goals were at different
times during the pandemic period uh
section B the level of disruption that
um the state's actions cause to
individuals um so individual citizens
residents of the State of New Hampshire
uh item C the level of economic
disruption that resulted from uh these
actions D um education which is pretty
broad encompassing um the the fact that
we uh as a state perhaps not as a state
but more as local entities um shut down
schools for extended periods of time um
that there was
conflicting um basis for
opening
uh section e um takes a brief look at
the executive legislative and judal
judicial functioning during the uh
period of time during the pandemic
especially the the most um significant
period of government actions which would
have been during the 2020 to 2021 mid
2021 period of
time uh section F deals with different
levels of government the integration uh
coop op operation and
Communications major section three deals
with
specific measures that were taken um by
the government
to uh attempt
mitigation of these uh of the pandemic
and of the virus subsections a talks
about social distancing the uh various
testimony we've received various um
uh scientific evidence and opinion as
well that we've received on it section B
uh on masking uh again the various
testimony um evidence opinion that we've
received on it um and brief analysis
section c um orders relating to anti-
assembling and closures of uh various
things from businesses to houses of
worship and the like
section D deals with vaccines and the
MRNA prophylactic technology that we've
had various testimony as to whether
those should technically be called
vaccines or not I I didn't intend to
weigh in on whether they are so I wanted
to make sure it was all
encompassing e uh having to do with the
equity measures that were taken by the
state of New Hampshire government F uh
on engineering controls and actually I
found this to be one of the most
interesting items that we saw and
perhaps one of the most important
recommendations going
forward um regarding the
the the fact that public health
authorities seem to be reticent to
recommend a high dollar policy that
might have had a very might have had a
great degree of success just because it
was a high dollar policy and trying to
solve in the future policy decisions
regarding spending money when it may
actually necessary to do so um and
finally G the ongoing impacts uh on the
health of New Hampshire residents uh as
was recommended by the committee last
week in our Friday session um making
recommendations or asking our federal
delegation perhaps to uh look at ongoing
um study and funding for uh long covid
and the vaccine
injured so that's the overall outline um
and happy to go through it bit by bit if
that
very
um uh Madam chair and and committee
Members First of all I just want to say
again that um this has been a uh quite a
journey I think for all of us I I think
that we came to this committee probably
with quite different ideas and beliefs
as to how the as to how the uh covid
response rolled out um we've heard a lot
of
testimony um I've talked to my fellow
and I just want to say that I can see
that there was an extraordinarily amount
huge amount of effort that
representative beler put in in in
drafting this it very much reflects um
his opinion of the of of the testimony
that we received um I've talked to uh
the other members they were not able to
come today
unfortunately um I would just say as a
general statement we have many many
points of
disagreement um with the report
um I'm willing I mean I can we can walk
through this and and look at the
language honestly I feel like it's going
to be incredibly difficult for us to
come to a consensus in a way that we
would be able to sign off on it because
I think we just basically disagree with
um a lot of the statements and
conclusions um I you know so just for
what it's worth uh we can stay we can
say that that I think there's
some anyway I'll just leave it at that I
I just want to keep it at a a respectful
level and just I wanted to say that on
behalf of the democratic members of the
committee thank you and uh represent
Merchant did send out uh an email to to
the members which I appreciate um let me
ask a question
on the
introduction is any is that an issue uh
of this I mean I'm just trying to find
out um I know uh representative we's
made out uh made some changes um that he
felt because he thought you know it was
more represent we what do why don't you
talk to us about some of the changes I
haven't seen that email come through yet
um
uh okay go ahead
yes my apologies the uh system has not
been kind to me this morning okay okay
so give you a few more minutes
representative po
off uh I have a question to the chair if
you can could outline um the process
that we are engaging right now uh our
deadlines and process uh um uh we heard
about signing off on report is it a
process that is ahead of us and uh I
understand that there are some uh uh
grammatical um uh suggestions and some
undertones that uh we want to change in
the report but I also think it's
important that we will finish with the
report uh so that uh we we don't miss a
deadline and there was some uh different
opinions about when the deadline is and
if we are able to continue our meetings
after today so if you have any
information on
that um I did not check with the uh
speaker's office but our report did not
have a deadline in there and it is a
special committee and a standing
committee so one I don't know don't
think that today is a deadline we are
all elected officials until I think
December 3rd um so as elected officials
we can still function I think in a
capacity of producing a report
I can double check with the speaker's
office on that quickly um but I think
it's important that we go through this
and um and I know that you've made some
changes representative weary that you
felt that were necessary um for the tone
of this report um but first off I don't
think I think that we need to recognize
that represent representative beler
taking on this under task I mean we all
have our biases um so when we write
things we have to understand that that
happens
and the tremendous amount of work that
he has put into this um to get us to
this point I think really needs to be
acknowledged um definitely uh so we now
have something that we can work with so
I think you
know if we can go through maybe section
by section um you know let's just look
at the introdu C ction and then and then
if you have notes on different sections
on where you think that there there's
problems or maybe represented where
already has suggestions that may be
amendable
to um we can hear those I think it's
important that we hear what um we hear
uh what the issues are and what uh
suggestions are already uh out there to
be made so um so you know I agree with
you that this was an enormous task and I
also uh thank representative Belcher for
taking it on and putting it all together
um I we got it I mean I'm not causing F
I'm just saying we got it late it was uh
an extremely long and comprehensive
document I did
not make specific comments on the
language because there was just so many
points of disagreement I didn't I wasn't
like in the process of of editing it um
I would I mean I can look at the
introduction again now I just you know
like I guess what I'm saying is I read
through the thing the the document I
didn't go back through and make notes I
just sort of paid attention I think
obviously we can agree on the on the
mission I'll look at the introduction
again but I think after that that's
where we begin to start to uh separate
um structurally usually what I've seen
is like
um text and then like bullet points with
a bunch of specific findings and then
after that you have a recommendation
section and then it it goes on from
there I've seen much more
footnoting um you know references we're
going to need some
appendices just technically speaking you
talk about the the people that came and
testified um you know that part of it
regardless of whether we agree to it or
not I would recommend that it be beefed
up if um if possible so anyway just with
overview any thoughts from the
committee represent
Bel thank you madam chair and I
appreciate all of the the comments that
have been made um I just wanted to
outline because we did have um a
discussion in a broad sense about what
the report ought to perhaps look like
and include this past Friday um I did
very much try to be cognizant of all
those things and including those
including um some things that we I
really went out of my way to try to make
um amable to all parties that I I've not
included any names of persons um
references are by title or by Branch
only uh nobody in the report is
disparaged or thrown under the bus in in
any way um
there are no recommendations for
punitive measures or actions or anything
of that sort it's all forward-looking
um in all circumstances it was
considered what was known at the time
trying very hard not to apply what we
might know now to judge actions at the
time based on what they may not have
known at the time
um we agreed I think as a as a committee
this past Friday that um when the state
is going to be adopted any sort of uh
official state position uh when it comes
down especially from the federal level
or anywhere else that we really ought to
be putting in the effort to
independently verify um that guidance
before we put our stamp as a state on it
and our legitimacy as a state government
on it
um it is noted many many many times that
the a lot of our response was dictated
guided or otherwise um
marshaled by federal authorities and not
by individuals or any parties or
branches of government within the state
um and lastly the the the findings for
um long Co and vaccine injury that we
discussed were also included in there
weary just please jump in um a question
to represent F thank you for sending uh
the draft is it um a version with
accepted changes because I I don't
necessarily see on my system but my
system is
different yes yes it is with the I
thought it would be easier for this
committee rather
than
um I I can send a if if someone wants
represent weary because we're not seeing
anything in red because obviously uh can
you discuss your changes please for
us um I it looks like you put the
mission first which I think is
important
um um bear bear with me for a second
while I open up I I
did I can send a track changes version
but it's pretty messy um but so
um basically I did move the the mission
to the top of the report I thought that
was best and I thought um you know I've
particularly noted in my reviews of the
videos early on before I joined the
committee as well as after I joined the
committee uh substituting for
representative leus that you know you
open up every meeting with this mission
statement and I think it it's important
for um you know reviewers of this report
to understand this specific Mission so I
thought it would be best to move that um
and then I included the metrics that um
just in terms of the hours of of public
hearings and the documented thousands of
pages that sort of thing and uh include
that then I identified you know the
composition of the committee and then I
listed with uh
the chair and the vice chair first and
then I just simply put in alphabetical
order uh represent weary there is one
change and I I didn't catch it uh and
looking at represent belches but it's
Kelly penzer and not Nikki Carter so
Kelly penzer is should be listed instead
of Nikki mcarter okay um
so so
so Kelly Kelly uh representative Penza
is listed um
below uh in the second column if you
look at that so you'll need to remove
Nicki mcarter okay um so there's got to
somewhere please Madam chair if I just
uh if this is the same and I think
probably is what I had I had just
included all persons even substitutes
that were on the committee during uh any
period of time um if we prefer not to
that's that's fine as well
um just the official memb should be on
there I think is important um um and if
I may real quick on page seven uh
representative weary uh near the bottom
there is an odd paragraph ending um I I
just want to make sure that's addressed
before I forget about it and move on
from it okay on the copy I sent let me
that please yes there are 12 names so
once we remove Niki Mar we are good baby
and representative weary I mean we can
always put uh
somewhere Alicia Le is then replaced
with representative weary um is is that
because that was official but uh
represent mcarter was only a substitute
so did you understand that
representative
wary if I wasn't originally appointed so
what we would like to say is have
representative leus there and then
um when she was no longer on the
committee replaced with representative
weary so that people understand that she
was the official member and then you
took over as an official member but
we're replacing
her I I'm I I leave it up to uh Mr Bel
representative belker to
uh okay make that adjustment if
he would please right because then you
did become a an official member of the
committee that's that was my
understanding
yes uh yeah yeah yes representative Bel
I think is talking about page seven if
you go to the for of Fifth Line from the
bottom you can see that uh paragraph uh
okay um I'm just noting what
representative Merchant said about
calling out the membership situation I
mean you could do that I guess but I
think that uh all of us who did not come
had a very specific conflict and we all
knew heading into this that Fridays were
going to be really difficult for us and
you know if you want to put that in
there uh if we're not signing off on the
thing that's your prerogative but it
seems like um
an unnecessary jab representative weary
out so in the in then in the new draft
removed
um represent Bel thank you madam chair
and just as a as as a quick sort of
um formatting question uh I would note
that the the last edit of the version
that I put out that was distributed
yesterday was ultimately a bit longer in
length because there was each section
sort of had it its own page or it was
each section started on a new page um
whereas this new one we're looking at
right now uh uh provided by
representative weary uh it retains the
older formatting where it's shorter
because it's not broken up in that
manner is there a preference that we
have for which way we ought to go with
that I I thought I thought better of it
and when I edit it maybe each section
starting on its own page but I I I just
was
curious maybe it it's cleaner that way I
I agree uh with each section on its own
page um especially when you're flipping
through an
index um but you know listening to what
representative eel said and represent
merch and uh citing some of um uh our
findings and putting in footnotes and
having addendums might be should
probably be put into this report
please thank you madam chair uh just to
address that and I I don't disagree that
it would ideally have all of those
things um the the difficulty for me was
we
have literally thousands of pages of
documents in our committee records and
and without the Staffing that somebody
like Congress has it it was just an
impossible task for me to try to cite
which is why where there was any any
necessary really necessary citation I
record again
it's it's it's up to you how you guys
want to handle this I mean if you're
quoting in the I mean I I believe we
just had one environmental engineer here
and if a lot of what you're quoting is
what he said then you could reference
him um some of the other statements that
were made came directly from say
attorney Siri or Dr korf as an
individual I think we could reference
those um we could at least have a
hyperlink to the AR report just you know
maybe if it's supposed supposed to be
somewhat scientific document uh or
summarizing science it would be good to
have some of those things but of course
we also have we can have an appendix
that's what I've done before and we can
list some of the documents and maybe
just references to them I appreciate
what you're saying representative belter
it' be a tremendous amount of work but
maybe we could add a few more things or
so I guess under under on represent
War's report did you make any changes to
section
okay that would be the first
did uh put on your mic please um why I
did with respect to the acknowledgements
is um I I took much of what was written
but
um uh kind of rewarded it for
readability I um
and
uh uh it looks like you shortened it a
little bit I I did okay why don't I just
read that section on what you changed
and see how it sounds to folks and uh
get an opinion um at the onset of this
report is important to recognize the
unprecedented nature of the covid-19
pandemic initially extraordinary little
was known about the virus the potential
degree of lethality and the rate of
transmissibility were being reported as
extremely
high throughout Society there was a
palpable fear that was exasperated by
the media's constant reporting of the
number of deaths that occurred due to
covid-19 indeed covid-19 and fear became
twin viruses infecting
Society because of the threat of the
virus and the growing sense of fear and
dread New Hampshire State officials no
doubt felt an enormous responsibility to
protect its citizens and to keep Granite
Staters alive and healthy to this end
the governor formed a committee of top
state leaders from several branches of
the state government to chart a path
forward to contain the spread of the
novel virus a well-known risk mitigation
approach for hazard prevention the Swiss
cheese model was enacted to mitigate the
spread of the virus decisions had to be
made quickly often times and I don't
know if often times is one word but
should be separated
um with minimal and or conflicting
information and the pressures and
challenges of making such decisions were
enormous ultimately the decision by the
committee in this approach were arguably
prudent measures to protect the people
of New Hampshire in undertaking a review
of these actions to mitigate the spread
of Co 19 virus this house committee
recognizes that decisions made during
the pandemic were done under immense
pressure with the information available
at the time accordingly this committee
has endeavored to determine how New
Hampshire can do better next time rather
than indiscriminately second-guessing
the decisions made with the 2020
hindsight furthermore this committee
also recognizes that New Hampshire had a
much lower mortality rate in comparison
to other states on behalf of the people
of New Hampshire we F feel compelled to
express appreciation to many officials
elected leaders and New Hampshire
citizens who made difficult decisions
under difficult circumstances to see New
Hampshire through the other side of the
pandemic it is the decision in genuine
efforts of these many people for which
the granted State owes a debt of
gratitude we also extend our thanks to
members of the public testifying before
our committee including Dr Jordan vaugh
The Honorable Betty gay attorney Aon
Siri Dr
korf uh Patricia Tilly commissioner
Caswell director buckton commissioner
edelblute and Dr Chan and many other
citizens Who provided valuable
information and offered unique
perspectives having made these
acknowledgements this report now returns
to the committee's mission to carefully
review the decisions made and evaluate
the actions taken to identify what we
might have done differently to better
protect the overall health and
well-being of the people of New
done it carries with it an
acknowledgment of extreme circumstances
and the high degree of work um that the
folks at the in the executive branch
frankly did and in the municipalities to
get us where we were so I mean I'll I
I'll read through it again but but
yeah right and and I think even in uh
represent belur and my original thing
was we wanted to make sure that everyone
understood that we're looking at this as
in hindsight that we weren't living
through that and we weren't dealing with
that and we have to be very thankful and
grateful so well and I think we could we
could say something about you know this
is being done um to the best of our
abilities Rec recognizing the
limitations of
our committee and Staffing and whatever
we could also say something like that
but you know whatever um I think I think
it has a good
tone I can represent P off so suggest
correction we we we list titles for most
of the mentioned people but not for
Patria and quick search shows that
she I I think she is a associate
commissioner so so we we can the title
that's right and I think if we put their
full names like I don't know what Dr
cuor
name so uh yeah so we need to fix that
put uh associate Commissioners uh
Patricia Tilly or Tilly uh and then it
would be Dr Martin kof if we're putting
in the full
names um yeah Taylor Caswell I don't
know who all I don't have it in front of
me right so Taylor casell Frank
edelblute I don't know what Dr Benjamin
Benjamin Ben Dr Benjamin and I'd have to
look up director Buxton and we can say
and many others who we did not have the
opportunity to hear from but certainly
were in the trenches or something like
that I mean I think they all really
knock themselves
out right and I think and many other
citizens Who provided valuable right so
I think uh and I think they were all
recognized at the at the beginning too
so I think but these were the people
that came and testified before our
committee
specifically representative P off uh I
have a question to the
committee uh so I think it's most of us
uh heard about uh the Swiss chese model
here for the first time so uh if we hear
I characterize it as a well-known risk
mitigation approach for hazard
prevention is it actually welln or or
not just a thought maybe we could have
um you know a footnote at the bottom or
something that talks what swiss cheese
method and what that meant just so some
okay thank well or maybe just not call
it that call it a variety of mitigation
measures or something like that just I
don't I don't have it in front of me so
uh we're just quoting uh right um
associate commissioner uh Tilly that she
said that several times times so uh
represent weary uh Dr Chan also
mentioned it several times and as a uh
someone with a long history in quality
and Regulatory in the pharmaceutical and
bi biotech and medical device Industries
I've been familiar with this for a long
long time and so uh we constantly use
that sort of model when talking about
risks uh you know aseptic processing
Sterile Processing other scenarios like
that so it is well known at least in
some Industries and I think in the in
the fields you know like that Dr Chan
would would frequent it should be
familiar
so okay so maybe a footnote just so
would people um uh understand what that
meant um thank
you please I did I did provide an
explanation of it so if you if you go
the text now has that explanation so I
thought any um there was another
instance where say the r not value was
discussed and so I I explained that I
explained the Swiss Cheese model so that
I I felt those two and maybe one other
thing that doesn't come to mind right at
the moment needed a
um General explanation of a technical
matter and so I I provided that in in my
uh version of the report okay thank you
perfect go ahead represent
B thank you madam chair and just to I'm
on currently on page 22 of 33 of the
updated the the uh edited version um I'm
on page
six I just wanted to chime in and say uh
thus far I am generally in agreement
that it makes it a little bit easier to
read it add some good information that
is good uh thus far I would not have a
problem with changing it to this version
maybe reformatting a little bit but I
think it's pretty
okay I'm going scrolling here right so
um go ahead represent where it yeah just
um
I ju I'm not trying to Pat myself on the
back but just for the record there's
probably about 8 to 10 hours of editing
in here so just just so people are aware
I didn't casually look at this and blah
blah blah you know I I really tried to
go through it and and
uh Prov provide some
um I think style and and content updates
to the excellent work that
representative velker had already
provided
I I I wonder if it would make sense so
that we're all dealing with your
document if we could ask house committee
services to just make a copy for us
because I don't send that right up there
I can I'll send that right up and then I
think that way we know we all are
okay otherwise it's really hard yes and
I I no I would tend to agree with that
and seeing the knowing the original
draft obviously and seeing the level of
changes that were made um almost every
single sentence in here has at least
small changes and improvements I think
so it would be almost impossible to go
through it as a side by side and say
this is this is what changed it would be
better just to deal with the edited
think but I
um uh representative belker and I were
discussing this uh briefly earlier prior
to the committee's convening and
um um I'm not as loquacious as
representative belker so my my uh
sentences are a little shorter generally
thank
you no no no no offense
but I'm I like
short and concise no I'm a business
writer not a English be somewhat
difficult for me because now the rest of
my folks haven't necessarily seen this
draft but you know we'll do the best we
yeah may
I and Ju Just to just to help comment a
little bit on that uh where I'm at I'm
now on page
23 the the changes are
overwhelmingly stylistic and grammatical
and taking my overwhelmingly
philosophical
style of writing and transforming into a
more technical style of writing but the
content um
uh why don't we take a 15 minute re uh
10 minute recess until uh 10:55
recess
e
uh I'd like to call us back into
reconvene it is now
10:55 so and I'd like to thank uh
represent of eel for uh G going and
getting these uh new uh reports uh so
that we can look at them thank
you and representative warry if you have
anything uh want to go over anything
um
so
um in the summary of
findings
I so so we we have them we have now both
documents right so maybe if we have them
side by side if there's anything in
particular you want to point out you
can't point out everything we also have
helps
um on on your computer do you have where
you change things I mean I already see
that there's a formatting change on some
of it um you know with bullet points and
things can already see
that uh please represent beler apologies
Madam chair I uh I seem to have two
copies of the same document is that what
we're supposed to be looking at uh well
I had printed out a copy of yours um and
brought it with me and then we have a
copy of Representative Wares and I
believe representative eel printed out a
copy of uh your report
also so that we brought from home but
please go ahead uh just to clarify
because what I'm looking at are are
exactly identical they are I think these
are both the edited version by
representative
got no she printed out the right thing
so one two three four five
right an extra copy um of that so you
have both you have the extra copy so got
it
I don't know why I was thinking six but
whatever so should I continue with the
summary of findings so basically
um I I I brought out the um I sort of
relabeled Representative Bel belker
introduced that there were kind of three
primary objectives I sort of relabeled
the second one because it was
um I I think
it it
was Bas and I did this based on Dr
Chan's discussion or testimony um
because it's he talked about uh a
genuine concern about the Health Care
system and infrastructure being
overwhelmed and so slow the spread was
the slogan or stop the spread or that
sort of thing two weeks to stop the
spread or slow the spread um but it but
the purpose or objective was really to
prevent the Health Care system and
infrast structure from being overwhelmed
so um and then I thought it was helpful
in this particular instance to really uh
call them out as individual you know
bullet points or numbered points so um
so I I did that and
um and and and then uh a lot of what is
there
[Music]
in uh like the the paragraph with the
that starts out the first major goal is
basically takes the same content but
just rewords it in
um for
readability um the
paragraph uh on analysis of the efficacy
of the response on toward the bottom of
page six is basically again the same
with a few minor rewords the paragraph
that starts with the second goal
is then that is um a more substantive
change because I thought it was
important
to
um explain
that that the concern about the the
concern about the overwhelming of the
Health Care system and so that
information is is uh Amplified and added
to to a degree and and um I built it in
terms of a sequential series of thoughts
to kind of better explain why this was a
concern and um then talked about some of
the points that representative belker
raised but I I for instance I labeled
the the approach to gain additional time
to improve treatments as sort of a
secondary benefit but the the primary
interest or purpose or goal or objective
was indeed to uh prevent the Health Care
system from being overwhelmed because
the the thought process was uh as I
remember at least more recently from the
testimony from Dr Chan was that there
was a a very much a concern that if this
Health Care system was overwhelmed and
was unable to help anyone at that point
because of a collapse of the Health Care
System then um you know you you have um
the catastrophe of the healthc Care
infrastructure being collapsing on top
of the virus pandemic so um so that's
then explained uh you then have in
starting at the top of page seven well
that's a continue paragraph but um then
I I broke out the the aspects of the
federal level versus state level and in
the paragraph that says at the federal
level then um then in the next one
uh that starts representatives of the
Department of Health and Human Services
described the Swiss cheese M there in
that particular paragraph I went into
some uh great detail about what that
analogy means and and so that the reader
could better understand that then in
the
um in the final paragraph at the bottom
of page seven
um that is basically the again the same
sort of
um content but um largely
reworded and then uh there were also
some
um sections that probably were taken out
at that point um just a quick note and I
think this is what everyone was pointing
to on page six was uh in in the
paragraph that says Representatives at
the very end of it it says accordingly
this committee um so whatever you were
thinking at that point um is not there
and I believe representative evil wanted
comment answer that did you drop a
sentence or was it's just a weird
paragraph
um let me uh give me just a moment thank
you while you're looking I guess so I'm
I'm looking at this and I'm trying to
figure out what is the specific finding
so you have goal one and I think the
finding
here uh is
basically uh if the goal was to Halt the
spread of the virus the objective was
not achieved by the state correct and it
says here the committee received no
information or testimony that would lead
us to believe that even a single
resident of the state was spared in
infection since since it first appeared
finding I believe that is almost a
direct quote from the right original
report right so that's what I mean all
I'm saying I'm trying to there there's
the building of the argument and then
there's the finding so I think that's
the finding the summary of the finding
for the first goal so I I just I wanted
to make sure that that was the the
finding and then wherever I mean I
haven't read it all we can find your
specific finding or findings for the
second
goal
uh um here we go the I so I think
the the the finding to the second goal
really
begins at the top of page nine or toward
the top of page nine maybe the first
first or second paragraph because then
the lastly in the middle of page n
really gets start Begins the discussion
of the third
point and that that sort of follows
repres representative belker's
um wording and I just I kept that
wording but uh tried to because it's a
one of the longer sections of the report
I tried to kind of uh keep with the
first second and third but you know know
introduce it as numbered points above um
just thank you madam chair if I could uh
just help to summarize a little bit what
we're what we're discussing especially
for anybody who might be watching at
home um we're looking at the uh summary
of findings regarding the efficacy of
the government response
now in order to determine whether or not
the government response was efficacious
whether it worked you first have to
identify what the goal was so we've
identified um rather I and
representative weary and in his edit
have identified several items that were
repeatedly testified to us that
represented goals during different
points in the pandemic the first goal
being that there was an attempt being
made
to uh not merely mitigate but really um
eliminate the spread of covid-19 uh the
SARS CO2 virus in an attempt to actually
not allow it to become endemic or native
to the population um so that was goal
number one uh as Dr Chan testified to uh
in a very direct question on this it
fairly quickly within couple months it
seems became apparent to the authority
ities involved that this was no longer
something reasonable to try to achieve
and the goal began shifting to a
mitigation strategy in order to try to
avoid there was several reasons that
were given to try to avoid overwhelming
our health care capacity in system um
and to buy time for the further
development of Therapeutics um
prophylactics uh and such uh in order to
ultimately have the effect of reducing
morbidity and mortality of infection so
those are the kind of overriding goals
that were identified and then the rest
goes on to
analyze based on testimony and data
we've received um what that looked like
and whether or not It ultimately worked
which in many cases it does not appear
to of at the very least we can say that
there wasn't evidence presented to us in
any sort of data format that could ident
identify any particular measure that we
took that actually was effective in
goals okay it's going to take a little
bit for us to go uh through this and
read it
um again uh
uh he said that on page nine where it
said lastly that would be the third
Point related
finding the third Point okay let's
see
um uh so what representative e eel is
asking is that uh the third goal um that
was stated we know that it's it starts
on page nine
uh on what we must examine but where was
the committee's findings on
that
so
recommendations begin at the bottom of
page 10 the top or the bottom two
paragraphs are where uh it states like
the committee recommends I see where it
says the committee recommends further
investigation second paragraph from the
bottom yeah page 10 yeah so those would
be I think sort of the findings there's
some um I really believe the the
paragraph above those two is
still a discussion of you know the
conflicting data that the committee
or
um not all conflicting data but just
um uh concerns expressed particularly as
I remember it from citizens who
experienced adverse reactions from the
vaccines and that sort of thing so I
think um
that's what that paragraph speaks to and
then and then as as indicated the
committee recommends those two
paragraphs below that uh provide you
know sort of the findings and
committee it's just not exactly a
finding but whatever I mean like on nine
we say it's the finding of the committee
that blah blah blah on seven I think we
were six we had a finding for the first
goal so I just thought maybe calling it
out a little bit more specifically and
building the recommendation from there I
I should say I don't I'm not imp I don't
want to imply that I necessarily agree
with this assessment it's just my
beler yes uh thank you I just wanted to
clarify because I know at least some of
this is sort of my original language so
when we're discussing findings
um and perhaps to my my fault I
shouldn't have used the word finding
once or twice in the context that I did
because it implies that that was perhaps
our only finding where in reality
everything after
the paragraph um that says lastly you
know this is was was the goal everything
after that constitutes a a finding um
with the sort of highlighted finding
being a something that was sort of an
overriding finding of the committee
recommendations okay
so this is going to be a long process I
know some of us uh would like to hear
more about what it is I know there's uh
going to be need more discussions um
about this
reports um and that we will need another
meeting
[Music]
um so I guess um I'd like to ask
representative eel um
you know once this report has now been
sent to the entire committee um so
everyone on the committee now has this
in their in their email
um what kind of time do do you need
to to look at it um go over it um Etc um
and we'd like to hear what your
suggestions are
thanks um well I guess my first question
would be
uh in this
revision representative weary did you
actually change any of the conclusions
is there anything really different in
here other than revising and amplifying
and the change the original document no
I I I really didn't I think the uh I
would say with with one possible
exception as I brought out the impact uh
during the discussion of the impact on
the educational system I brought out the
impact on um early childhood development
and
socialization that uh mass and school
closures had on children we heard that
um a few times and both from experts and
concerned citizens and our own
representative leus who has a lot of
experience in that area and so I think
from um that aspect um I I uh it may
have been me mentioned briefly
um but I I brought that out in
particular as I said I I think I changed
really the second point
from um an emphasis on slow the spread
to really teasing out more the aspects
of preventing the Health Care system
from being overwhelmed
and um and then the rest you know and as
I said uh perhaps earlier I did try to
explain some of the technical aspects of
uh the Swiss Cheese model the r not um
value and
um I think there I think there was one
other thing but I don't I don't really
remember it offand um so but to to
really kind of fundamentally answer your
question no I did not change the
conclusions or the you know the findings
or the conclusions of the
report uh it's a lot of this was
really I I think stylistic and uh just
you know for readability and then to
also to um you know part of readability
meaning explaining some of the technical
Concepts as we came across them in the
uh I I think in in some cases you know
just um maybe rearranging some thoughts
to uh for the purposes of conciseness I
think but um you know so there was a lot
of stylistic editing but not quite
frankly very much content-wise okay
um so to answer your question I I don't
quite know how to move ahead on it I
think that if the content really is not
changed and the findings and the
conclusions are not really changed I
don't think the position of our members
will change um
so the alternative would be for us to
provide um a statement to that effect
that could be included in the
report I mean and whether that requires
a whole other meeting or if we meet and
then I just bring that in I mean or if I
email it to you I mean I think that's
basically that's basically where we
stand okay represent beler thank you
madam chair and I would it be possible
just call a brief five minute caucus on
on the topic just to make sure we're all
on the same page I'll go caucus with
myself sorry representative evil but uh
we
uh
11:25 we'll take a brief recess till
you
e
e it is now 11:25 I'd like to reconvene
the meeting um couple things I think
that
um we should give the other committee
members a chance to review the edited
version I think out of respect for
everyone's time um I think that's
important
um
uh you know if we want to have more
discussion about this today we can um or
we
can uh I'll schedule another meeting uh
for the week of the 11th and my
availability um I was thinking let me
I we we are in busy busy times
um but uh Wednesday uh November
13th
um I have some things scheduled in the
afternoon but I could be here at 9 in
the morning I know that's early for some
of us um but I didn't know if that was
uh
doable um because I have some traveling
and some other things going on that week
um that I have to take care of um so uh
I just want to throw that out there uh
so I believe that is the
13th at 9:00 a.m. and I just want to
throw that out and see what everyone
thinks about about
that represent Bel thank you madam chair
I think that would be uh I think that
would be acceptable and good I wanted to
ask would we like to
extend um as was requested the
opportunity to draft a a statement that
we could receive preferably before that
and then also discuss that day from the
members unfortunately I'm on a panel
that morning from 9:45 to
so I don't know what to say and I'm away
the 14th and 15th I mean the only other
thing is if you
want um if you want to schedule it some
to tell you the truth other people may
be able to come I'm thinking about this
other people may be able to come or
alternatively if they can't we would um
provide you either with a statement or
something uh for that that day okay um
all right it's it's
okay
okay Weir to agree to a meeting when I
know that I can't come but I I you know
uh perhaps representative Merchants
available merant or representative groa
will be able to come and at that point
we will have put together what I will
assume will be a relatively brief
statement and then you can just you know
add it to the report
okay um okay so um you know what I'm
off uh I wonder if anyone uh personally
I'm also available on Tuesday 12 uh and
also representative Bela wanted to make
a
comment thank you madam chair um I was
just going to recommend perhaps that if
uh representative eil is available at
10:30 that morning if we wanted to plan
to convene at 9: having a statement and
our our report which by the way because
there are a few minor changes in
representative wary has expressed that
he is um very busy given us some
personal circumstances what I can do is
I can just go make the few modifications
to the edited version to make sure that
there aren't like you know sentence
fragments um and have that also
available prior to going in that way we
can discuss it for a little bit knowing
that uh representative Evel will be able
to be here approximately 10 30 years
panel and well it's the NR you know the
the the I don't know it's a trash thing
I'm on up so I'm in I'm gonna be in
Epsom and it rounds up it it ends up at
11: and it's an in-person thing so I
can't I think it's going to be hard I
appreciate that but I think I can't get
here in the morning yeah she she won't
be able to be here uh cuz she's going to
be in my neck of the woods yeah
I'm G to be over in Epsom so it' be
really hard I mean if I was in conquer
or if it was a zoom or something i' do
so thank you madam chair well in that
case perhaps I could recommend that um
we just make sure we have at least at
least one Democratic member here if
either one of them who's here or if you
want to name somebody to introduce the
at least to introduce the the the
statement and that way we can discuss it
and move forward and you know it'll be
our statement so whatever it says it it
it says um and so did you say there's
going to be a few more tweaks to
representive we's draft so then you'll
redistribute it yes and I I'll do that
and it's it's not going to be serious
you know content changes or anything
there's just a few little little
sentence fragments or something like a
paragraph that ended on
a I also believe that representative wry
right now he's uh going through a tough
uh personal time time right now uh we'll
have time maybe later next week uh to go
over some things too um and so I'd like
to out of respect for him um I would
like to give him some time to do that
sure represent weary yeah thank thank
you madam chair I I um I appreciate that
yeah
um
um uh my my father passed away this past
Thursday a week or a week ago and um and
um
uh I think uh after after this next week
I think I'll be able to um address
things and and perhaps uh represent
belter and I can uh meet and you know uh
and iron out the uh any wording word
smithing or things that need to be
clarified thank you appreciate that yeah
I'm sorry about the my my mother died
two years ago at exactly this time and
it's still a tough could I suggest when
you guys do if you could do some
appendices that sort of outlined
specifically who your Witnesses are and
maybe just a list of your key documents
I mean the way this is going to work out
it's going to be a document that lives
online under our committee so you could
do some hyperlinks in it to some of the
key not everything but some of the stuff
that you found particularly persuasive
in in developing your your
findings I if we uh if for example we
had a a link to a particular testimony
and then had underneath that um some of
the major topics that that witness
testified to um so rather than trying to
provide links throughout the report to
to Mr representative belker's earlier
statement I think that might be useful I
mean honestly I think it would also give
more oomph to your to your document um
and anyway so just so you know if you go
on to our website and you see our
standing committee then it says at at
the bottom it says committee links and
we do have on here like the after action
report is already there
um I believe
um uh representative Alicia comments her
testimony is is there uh her written
statement uh and we have a few other
documents if anyone thinks of any other
documents that needs to be uploaded onto
this um let me know and we can ask um
Jamie to do that for us please represent
Belair represent poov had something
first I just want to agree with what
representative AEL said and I I I
understand that 12 days it seems a lot
and maybe we won't have enough time to
put every uh every link but as much
documentation as we can provide in the
report it will be really helpful for
those who will be dealing with it in
future represent Belair thank you madam
chair and uh just on that topic of
what's currently on the website um and
what needs to be there uh and references
in the report uh I think we can do some
work to to make some references that are
appropriate where possible um the
references may be extraordinarily broad
given how much I myself have
introduced probably several dozen or
more documents not not including the
totality of executive and emergency
orders that were issued during the
pandemic um so if if the if the request
is to have some hyperlinks that will
reference what is already in the report
um to substantiate findings and claims
we're if possible going to need the
entirety of documents that have been
introduced into the committee through
these previous emails to be uploaded um
and hyperlink on under our Committee
website I mean I think you can just feel
your way along I mean even like for Dr
Jordan vaugh you could put his name and
you could put a link to his website or
something I mean just some things like
that I do think on the executive orders
I agree with you that really important
we should have um something on that I
would bet that there may be a place
living on the governor's website that
you can find those executive orders and
to some extent you know the committee
researcher may be able to help you uh
with this I also want to make sure
stating the obvious that the link for
the
committee is in the document if you know
what I'm saying I don't see it right now
but we want to give a link to where all
our our stuff
is but I do think it's important that we
have an appendix that lists the the uh
Witnesses and you can give a link to
their organization if you want and and
on I I mean I would think the researcher
too I think that's a very good idea so
anybody else have anything they'd like
to discuss I think uh does everyone
agree on an
appendix uh making sure we get
everything up on the uh into our
website uh Etc and I will reach out to
uh our researcher um and ask her to you
know link some of the things and maybe
she can link like even uh the Homeland
uh security uh Homeland Security report
um and and uh I think the co timeline
report is especially important to be up
there uh right so that after action
report right so um those those items I
think would be important to have on our
on our website also we'll live in two
places but redundancy is not a bad thing
sometimes because sometimes people are
just going to be looking at our the
report so the only other thing and maybe
I missed it part of our charge was the
issue of uh dissemination of federal
funds that's what uh commissioner
Caswell had talked about is that in here
in
some
way if I if I may uh on that
one uh when I was writing it I didn't do
a deep dive into it frankly just because
the executive has already done and
provided a deep dive into it so I think
if we wanted to Simply reference their
work which is is quite extensive on that
I think we don't need to duplicate that
effort yeah I mean I think it just just
because it was part of our charge I
think if you reference that that in some
helpful anything else I mean this is all
good stuff so uh you know we want to
make sure that all the information is
available to everyone that we heard and
saw so
um okay
so I guess uh what did I say
November 13th at 9:00 a.m. um okay great
so is the idea that the final blessing
of the report will be on that day and
we'll bring our happy crew to a
conclusion yes
please I don't know about no the 13th I
don't know it's a Wednesday though okay
okay Friday not a Friday I'm glad
somebody's as superstitious as I am
unfortunately um all right well thank
you everyone I appreciate it everyone uh
have a great weekend um I don't know if
everyone's uh on the ballot next time
but good luck to everyone who is and
I'll
see not everyone on the 13th and I wish
you on the other side yes and uh good
luck at your meeting on the 13th all
right yeah thanks a lot all right uh we